thank you everybody
thanks for inviting me
i'll be talking about a topic modeling
approach
for rank aggregation this is joint work
with our graduate student wakang ding
and
a faculty member prakash ishwar
and uh
and so this this talk is kind of like
david stock in fact it resembles his
previous work that he did in 2009 i
believe and we have sort of followed on
that that type of work it also has users
and items and things like this and
hopefully i'll confuse you more by the
end of this talk
okay
so what is the main contribution of this
talk at least the take home message if
you completely get lost in all of the
modeling details and things like that
there is this entire field now that has
been developed called topic modeling
we are going to what we are going to do
is to suggest a new generative model
for ranking and comparisons and things
like this and we want to show
that
hidden inside rank aggregation problems
is nothing but a topic book topic
modeling problem in disguise so our
first task is to just show the
equivalence between rank aggregation
problem and the topic modeling problem
for pairwise comparison so that will be
my first task hopefully i'll be able to
convince you about that
then we want to what we want to do in
this rank aggregation problem is to
capture the fact that the hu users are
heterogeneous
just like devorah's example different
people have different likes and dislikes
so we want to capture the heterogeneity
and
at the same time we want to also capture
the erratic behaviors of different users
which means they could be inconsistent
and they could rate the same two items
in different ways when offered the same
two items okay
so if they like movie one versus movie
two uh if you offer them there may be a
small probability that they may switch
okay so that is that is another thing
that we want to
want to
point out now
this will lead to a new generative
algorithm and this new generative
algorithm hidden behind all of these
algorithms is this idea called latent
variable models so there is there are
things what you observe
it can be modeled as something latent
coming out of latent mixture of latent
things and when you have these types of
latent models automatically there is
something called separability that
emerges
this notion of separability then leads
to
a specific
extreme point finding algorithm that can
be generalized across these different
types of latent variable models so we
can exploit this geometric structure of
these latent variable models to actually
get polynomial sample complexity and
computational complexity for extracting
an estimating predicting and things like
that for from these user item
systems and eventually these could also
be used for recommendations okay and
then we will show empirical performance
on
is exactly movie lens data set
unfortunately that is that appears to be
the one data set that is publicly
available so everybody uses that so
we'll be showing some performance on
that
okay
okay so so for i'm i'm just explaining
what a topic modeling is for those of
you who have never heard of topic models
so you have a text document
and from that text document you extract
all of the words and how this is
extracted is itself a different subject
that i do not want to get into but
somehow words important words from this
document get extracted and once they get
extracted these are the words so these
are the different words so topic is
simply
a set of words and their frequencies so
there are different counts of these
words in this text document so this is
your observation
this is kind of always your observation
that you have to be aware about
now once you do that
what you have a fundamental model which
says that the counts that you observe
is a latent mixture of some underlying
topics that you do not know and the goal
of topic modeling is to figure out these
topics where topics themselves are in
distribution over words so you want to
express these counts as though coming
from a latent mixture of these topics
that you have to determine
what does latency mean
what does latent mean latent means
hidden
meaning
something that you have to estimate
latent means
so a document here is a mixture of
hidden topics
okay where topic itself is a
distribution over words
okay so what does this have to do with
rank aggregation problems so in rank
aggregation problems you have user
preferences using these user preferences
you can
you can lift them to the notion of a
word what is a word i can think of a
word as a comparison between any two
movies so i have movies here and these
are two different movies and this
particular user rates this movie over
that other movie which means
that you you have these things called
counts exactly as you have you have
counts in the previous
topic modeling situation
now underlying these counts how these
counts emerges we can also come up with
a generative model which is which we can
call as influencing factors so
some users may be overly influenced by
an actor some users can be influenced by
the fact that there is a movie some some
others could be influenced by something
called special effects okay so those are
different
different types of influencing factors
that lead to these comparisons what you
get to observe is are only these user
preferences from those user preferences
you get to observe these comparisons for
each user
okay so we can see what emerges you can
lift every user
to be a document as in a topic model you
can lift every word to be a comparison
and the number of times these
comparisons go one way or another to be
the comps
yeah
so there is no notion of
anti-word right in the sense one greater
than two versus two greater than one
you're losing that information we'll get
to this point yeah we do we we do
incorporate it just for simplicity and
i'm mentioning this yeah
okay so let's go go back to what is the
model okay so let me at least try to
explain what's the topic model
so here are all the words that have been
that that we have counted so this is
number of times dna has been described
number of times
genes have been described and so on
these are frequency patterns underlying
these frequency patterns in this
document
is
these different
actual free actual probabilities with
which those words occur so these are
documents and the documents are
producing these counts and these are m
different documents
a topic is a mixture of these different
words so for instance genetics leads to
one kind of frequency of different
words whereas data leads to a different
frequency words for instance the word
dna could appear much more frequently in
topic one whereas word
data could appear much more frequently
in
the thing so by a topic mixture or a
latent mixture one means that you're
only given
this guy
and your task is to determine
this decomposition between this and this
so each document is a different mixture
of these different topics and different
documents
constitute different mixtures okay so
you are given this particular matrix and
from this matrix you should determine
this and that okay so now the question
is how does this relate to our rank
aggregation problem
okay
so first of all we need to figure out
what what does one mean by a a topic
matrix like we did for the topic
modeling problem so in the
in in the
in the topic modeling problem it's
fairly clear
what what the topic matrix means
okay so for genetics you have different
frequency for these words in data
science you have different frequencies
for those words
so what does it mean in in the case of
rank
for the rank ranking problem
so again there are different
topics the topics are going to be
different amounts of
basically each component of this topic
is going to be the probability
a movie 1 is preferred over movie 2. and
so the ranking matrix is each column is
like a topic and you have number of
ordered pairs q times q minus one and
you have k equals these number of topics
okay so the this basically is pretty
straightforward
now the question is how do you generate
such a topic matrix you need a
generative mechanism and the generating
mechanism can be one of two ways one is
called as the sampling sampling which is
from the space of permutations and that
goes to himanshu's question which is it
only goes one way right so here i'm
comparing one versus two one versus
three and i'm noting down this is a
binary matrix so i get so what is what
is each topic right each topic is a
permutation over all the possible
different movies and from that
permutation i am going to get you all
the binary comparisons 1 means 1 is
bigger than 2
here 1
here means 1 is bigger than two and two
one actually zero so if i rated one if
this particular ranking rated one bigger
than two and it necessarily means two is
getting rated less than one
so we can we can we can come up with a
noisy version of this case which is what
is called as the mallos model so you
have k different permutations to start
with and then you can make it noisy how
do you make it noisy you take every two
items at random
and then flip a coin with probability p
and if it gets flipped
you switch switch it and get a new
permutation
doing it this way means that you have a
distribution over these different
permutations
so you get a distribution over these
different permutations and if you work
it out it turns out to be this
distribution
so if you were to adopt the malos model
which is what we adopt then each one of
these components is the probability one
gets rated greater than two given this
baseline permutation sigma one and this
baseline dispersion parameter v1 so as
you can see as phi goes to 0
you get much more purer structure and as
p goes to 1 you get completely random
structure
okay so that's how
this works
so then everything is kind of clear
right so you have we used to have
documents topics and
these different mixtures now you end up
with users each user is a different
mixture of these different ranking or
noisy rankings as in the mallows model
so the goal simply so so one thing that
i want to mention is that you you are by
doing this you are capturing both
heterogeneity across different users why
because different users here are have
different mixtures of these underlying
rankings and you're also
incorporating inconsistency between
users why because the way the model
works is that you once you get
a 1 1 you toss a coin and with
probability a 1 1 you would rate 1
bigger than 2 and 1 minus a 1 1 you
would rate it
the other way around
okay
so
you you essentially have this matrix
which is the column equals pairwise
counts of a user and then the number of
times user m prefers i over j
once you're done with that
your goal is the following
you want given x and k you want to
estimate all of these different
parameters which is matrix factorization
and also do inference and prediction
what does inference in prediction mean
inference means that i want to compute
which mixture
applies to every user prediction means
when i have new users how do i predict
like what they wrote is talking about
for a new user okay
so there are just to put this thing in
in comparison to all the other work that
is in literature there's been a lot of
work in the last 10 years so there are
there is work based on single ranking
model so you only have one particular
column in this column matrix so
everybody shares this ranking
and the goal is to just find out this
ranking you have mixture of ranking
models
which which have been so they were worth
here
looked at these kinds of problems over
the last year and we have been looking
at
both
multiple shared rankings across
different users
so our work is very closely related to
fouriers at all in nip-09 and the main
idea here is that we are using mixture
of malus model which leads to
approximate separability that i will i
will point out in a few seconds
the main advantage of our model is that
from a computational standpoint we get
polynomial complexity in terms of
computation and we get polynomial
complexity in terms of sample complexity
in discovering these different
different things
so
this is the problem
and often one talks about
a plate model such as this and the plate
model is basically all that i've
described so far so i won't get into the
details again the main thing to realize
is that you can you can show complete
equivalence between topic modeling and
rank aggregation by associating
the number of words to be the number of
ordered pairs between
different items the number of latent
rankings to be the topics
the number of users
is the same as number of documents and
the number of comparisons per use
okay so this gives you a statistical
equivalence between
rank aggregation using pairwise
comparisons and topic modeling
okay so this is an important point that
i i want to mention because this leads
to a computationally tractable algorithm
so it turns out that whenever we have
these kinds of latent models
of generating documents
that this notion of approximate
separability emerges naturally so what
is the meaning of approximate sub
approximate separability what
approximate separability in this context
means is that if i take this ranking
matrix which is this beta matrix and
look at different rows of this beta
matrix then there exists at least one
row corresponding to every topic such
that it is predominant so for instance
the comparison one two
dominates
for topic one over other other
comparisons so beta1 is much larger
than
so one if one gets rated higher than two
in other topics one does not get rated
higher than two uh for these other
topics so
approximately separable just means that
there is exists at least one comparison
which is predominant for each factor so
here are three different possibilities
this kind of makes sense
let me argue why it makes sense consider
the extreme case where lambda equals 0
so when lambda equals 0 it means that a
novel comparison is unique to each topic
so let's try to understand this
supposing musical is an underlying topic
which is the influencing factor
then the fact that
sound of music which is a movie is
bigger than terminator
is gets rated in one way
because it's a musical topic whereas
in the action topic it never get gets
rated higher than sound of music because
sound of music is not rated higher than
terminator because terminator happens to
be the action action topic okay so
so we are this is a relaxation of
this setting
okay so this is a formal result what we
are able to show that under our
generative model
if the number of items q is fairly large
then you typically get approximate
separability which means that
you will have a beta matrix such that
there are at least
a certain set of rows such that
every
topic has a dominant
is dominates over all the other topics
for that particular comparison
and you can actually do
monte carlo simulations with our
generative model and actually see that
even for fairly small number of items
and topics you do get this kind of
behavior where you end up with
different notions of different amounts
of separability
so how does this separability idea yeah
there's a formal statement there
this this is the statement
probability that sigma is lambda
separable lambda is a number
and probability that lambda is sam
lambda's a problem is 1 minus k times
the exponent of minus q q is the number
of items times this number l l appears
to be log of lambda by log of e to the
power minus 2 to 2k
okay so as the number of items are
sufficiently large i mean this is a
loose bound actually we could
potentially improve this bound but if
this particular statement is saying
is that if the number of latent factors
is grows logarithmically with respect to
the number of comparison number of items
then you typically see this type of
behavior
so why does the separability help us
the separability helps us because if you
look at
a equals beta times theta
then
what happens if you look at the
different rows of a
the and look at the convex hull of the
different rows of a there are going to
be rows of a which look pure like this
theta 1 theta 2 and theta 3. and all the
other rows of a are convex combinations
of these particular rows
so separability immediately implies that
you get a picture like this
each comparison which is
novel
that means that it is compared one way
is going to be the extreme points
of
these the rows of this a matrix
so
every every time you get the
separability you will get approximately
this picture
that is there are going to be these
normal comparisons which are going to be
extreme points of these rows of a
and every other
comparison is going to be inside this
row of a you can see this from
a equals beta times theta and if you
have for instance this ranking matrix
which is a binary matrix then
1 0 0
corresponds to theta 1 here and then
2 1 is another novel pair and it
corresponds to theta 2 there and 3 2 is
another novel pair which corresponds to
theta 3 and all the other
rows of a
are just
lin convex combinations of this
okay so you end up with this picture
every time you are able to establish
that things are approximately separable
so now to just estimate the beta and
theta matrix is simply to figure out the
extreme points of this of this picture
okay how do you estimate the extreme
points of this picture which directions
to use you simply generate piid isotropy
directions
so you generate directions at random and
then look at
what
were what comparisons lead to the
maximum value what comparisons lead to
the minimum value collect all those
comparisons and those exactly correspond
to the extreme points and so you now
have
the extreme points from there you can
find the convex combinations for all the
other different comparisons
okay so why is this robust
well and why does it work for the
approximately separable case
because the solid angle subtended
by the extreme points is going to be
always much larger than the solid angle
subtended by the convex combinations so
because the solid angle subtended by
this most of the time you're going to
get a hit that this is a maximum point
and very few times are you going to get
a hit that this is a maximum point so by
just looking at sorting the k tag has k
different
counts and sorting them you're able to
figure out which ones pop out and which
ones don't and that turns out to be
the k different rankings that you could
figure out
okay so this is another result again
this is a theoretical result which says
that the computational complexity
in trying to
figure out the beta theta matrix
it grows linearly with respect to the
number of users linearly with respect to
the number of comparisons per users and
the number of random projections that
you ought to do
in this context okay
and
this is the
sample complexity
and this is stated in terms of
lambda being sufficiently small that is
lambda is approximately separable but
then as q goes to infinity you can prove
consistency because this is always
satisfied for our generative model again
the number of users as long as it grows
polynomially with respect to the number
of number of comparisons
and the number of different rankings
underlying rankings we are guaranteed
that you will you will definitely figure
out the beta and theta matrix within
with with high probability probability
at least one minus that
okay where delta appears here log over
minus
okay so i don't know how much time i
have but
just a minute okay so let me actually
show one thing and then
perhaps
end this
so this is a problem so this is
the movie lens data set
so remember that i was telling you that
it's not about just estimating but we
can also predict
how new users will perform how do how
can we do that once we have the beta and
theta matrix we can then generalize to
new
movies
and new
new users for instance if i get a new
movie
then i can ask you the question what is
the probability that this particular
movie has a certain rating so for
instance if there are five five ratings
star one rating star two rating star
three ratings star four rating and so on
so i can ask the question what is the
probability likelihood that this is a
star 4 rating
how does that relate to the problem it
because it generates induces certain
comparisons between a certain other
movies in the data set
so therefore you can compute the
likelihood
and once you compute the likelihood you
can then determine
uh
determine the basically the
recommendations for those users
or for those movies for a particular
user
so what this chart tells you
is that if you follow the bayesian
approach which is followed
bayesian approach there's a
well-known approach called bayesian
matrix factorization approach
then
and you compare it which is supposed to
be the state of art if you compare that
against our approach which is this mmm
which is mixed membership
model that i'm talking about we get very
comparable performance although we are
not using any monte carlo simulations
here or anything our pro our solution is
very simple
we proved that it is approximately
separable given that it is approximately
separable we just used random
projections to find which
comparisons are dominant using that we
figured out the beta and theta matrix
and once we figured that out we can now
predict for new users and that gives you
very comparable performance to the state
of art
okay
so let me conclude by saying that we
have looked at high dimensional mixed
membership models
and in these high dimensional mixed
membership models there is a geometry
which is approximate separability which
one could exploit in this context
so this gives you a very simple
geometric picture that is
this kind of a picture and this
geometric picture directly suggests an
efficient randomized algorithm which is
parallelizable and distributable
and from there you can get consistency
efficiency and state-of-art performance
thank you
question
yes
interesting uh
the main question that i have is how do
you know
when q is large enough in order to get
deceptive
that's a good question um
so we
we can come up with
bounds
we can come up with bounds for how large
q has to be
uh
but those bonds may not be satisfied
upon the particular matrix no those
bonds are dependent on the generative
model so given this generative model you
can come up with
uh wikiyama with bounds
right
so presumably you could do some
so in the topic modeling we exactly have
these bounce and much more the problem
with ranking is that there's a huge
correlation across these different
comparisons which makes the bouncer kind
of loose but in the topic modeling
context you indeed and interestingly
what happens is we have looked at
the way people actually solve like
latent dirichlet allocation which is a
topic modeling
software package is available and the
and the parameters they set
is so s it turns out to be so small that
it effectively they are solving for
these extreme points although they are
using variational methods or variational
machinery to do
that whereas this is a diff so the high
level idea here is that a lot of these
mixed membership models have a certain
separable structure and that separable
structure should be exploited in a very
clean way to and
you can get good complexity results by
doing that
that's perhaps the point
on that point about the separability so
for the mallard model
each topic has a separate permutation
and then this kind of noise around that
permutation right yes
so
the large q
giving you the the approximate
separability corresponds to even though
the permutations might be identical
essentially everywhere
there's noise well separability emerges
no it actually it's even simpler than
that
so let me go back to this picture
here
so look at this probability of this
permutation sigma given the underlying
permutation sigma g
this grows as phi to the power distance
between the two permutations sigma and
sigma j what does this
mean it means that the probability that
i'm going to have l flips so supposing i
have a ranking of 1 and ranking of l
okay and there are there is a distance
of l the probability i'm going to flip l
times is going down exponentially fast
so no matter
how i generate there is going to be
one versus l is going to be very very
small probability that it it is going to
be
l comma one
and that is how you are getting
approximate superglue
so if i have 1 and if i have in the
baseline model sigma j if i have a 1
and if i have l and there is a distance
of
l minus 1
then
this probability that i'm going to see l
and one flipped
is going to go down exponentially with
the distance between
between the rankings so eventually there
is going to be at least that row where
you're going to get
something large and something small
along that row
that's only true if you use the candle
cloud when you have a change yes this is
for kendall
so the mallows model is talking about
kendall tower
takes any distance function yeah so here
i am talking about kendall tower
distance right